maybe this is Mandelbrot set back to
basics I need your help though can you
think of a number 7 good can you square
that number 49 can you do this while
filming you've done it correctly so far
okay next question you're gonna get
upset Square 49 no okay good answer the
thing is I don't really care about the
answer what I'm caring about is an
iteration I can't keep asking you to do
the same thing again and again and if I
ask you to pick a number and keep
squaring it you already know what's
gonna happen right it's gonna get big
blowout is it square one okay okay good
now square half sometimes it blows up
and actually that happens when it's
bigger than one and it becomes quite
obvious when you try it but one doesn't
blow up so once different and numbers
less than one like 1/2 actually become a
quarter when you square them and that
becomes a 16th and so on but then
numbers much less than one like minus
six and that one's blown up as well so
what I'm really talking about and what
iteration is quite often talking about
is when iterations are stable when they
sort of head towards somewhere you can
see and when they're not and it's best
to see this on a diagram so have a look
at my screen here
you picked the number seven which is
kind of off my screen here but these red
arrows we're moving them around this is
not the greatest diagram let me get this
clear in this to start with it's just a
line but the arrows are head in that way
because when I square this number I'm
moving around they go that way and they
never come back much like your son did
but if I go less than this number one
they don't go that way anymore they go
that way in fact they head towards zero
and they're stable there so for the sake
of moving it around it's kind of nice to
see the difference is a really sharp
line then it completely changes behavior
but that way they're unstable that way
they're stable stable unstable stable
unstable they want stable unstable you
get the idea in fact if you go negative
they still stable their head positive
because we need to go a number that's
negatively get positive still head
toward zero until you hit minus 1 and
then unstable stable stable unstable
stable now despite all my commentary
it's not Maddox I think yet and if you
know anything about the theory of
iterations and the consequences of them
or if you've watched any other video
about the man that
you know that we're not just talking
about real numbers are your numbers on
and the line I've just been showing you
we're talking about numbers in two
dimensions so complex numbers and I'm
not gonna give you an introduction to
complex numbers here because I don't
think you need to hear it and there are
other places you can get them Holly on
the numberphile Channel has done
excellent videos about how this happens
but I want to show you the same comments
that she's made on brown paper I'd like
to show you moving here's my
two-dimensional number line here is the
number that you get to pick randomly we
can still do it in one dimension just by
sliding along here and the other dot
that's moving around this tiny one is
the square of the other dot so one
squared is about one bigger than one it
heads off that way lower than one goes
that way but I can move off the line now
and it has a weirdly circular flavor to
it which I kind of like it's like
chasing the number around it moves
quicker than you expect and that's
already quite pleasing if you're a nerd
like me but what I really interested is
the iteration if you keep doing the
interruption square it square a-square
we saw what happened on the real line in
two dimensions it looks different so it
looks like this
so this line indicates if we start there
it goes to there when you square it and
then to there and there and so if I move
this around the picture is kind of
pleasing kind of wobbles around but it's
always heading towards the center which
I'll say is stable and there's a reason
there's a circle on the screen because
anytime I'm inside this circle it looks
like it's stable even if it's kind of
pretty as it moves but if I go near the
edge of the circle it's less obviously
stable it takes a lot longer to get to
the center and then if I go outside the
circle unstable
stable unstable stable stable unstable
stable this is a really nice
demonstration of what complex numbers
are helpful in the instead of your
entire image of what's happening being
on a line you've got picture but it gets
better right instead of just squaring it
what would happen if you did square it
add something square it and something
square add something now we can go back
to the real line and see it happening on
just one dimension but I feel like we
should just go straight into two
dimensions this is just the square
square root square a-square if this
letter C is indicating a number I could
add every time so let me just slide it
away from zero the moment it's not
adding anything but if I add this number
this red number which is a complex
number is two dimensional you can see
something very different has happened if
I start with this number and I keep
squaring it and adding that number
square add that number square at that
number Square add that number this is
the path that goes and it makes a lovely
star shape what's interesting though is
not just a star shape although I kind of
like it is the stability so all around
here is stable it always gives you the
same sort of stability like a starry
stability even if it's expanding or
shrinking but you kind of get the
feeling that sometime it's gonna blow up
and it's not obvious where because if I
go near the circle you think that's kind
of like it's gonna blow but doesn't oh
so there with a moment there so outside
the circle still stable but somewhere
else outside the circle unstable and in
fact it's not obvious where this
happening stable unstable stable stable
unstable no stables do and but over here
inside the circle always stable and I go
there I keep saying the circle as if
it's important it's really not important
or the boundary is clearly not circled
but it's kind of nice to move this
around I think that some places are
unstable that some are stable what I'd
really like to see and I hope you were
too is the boundary of stability so
let's see that in fact let's look at the
boundary if the number I choose to add
each time is 0 you get the circle that's
like the simple iteration if you choose
to add something different by the way
I'm going I'm gonna write something down
here what I'm capturing is this
iteration which always looks a bit
technical and if I cover that bit up
it's what we did at the beginning I said
square a number and that's your new
number square it square it square it but
instead of just where
you square it add something there you
see four it's a constant but it's a
complex number now we're ready to look
at that if C is zero you get a circle if
it's not zero
I see where my brain melts a little
tight fit if C is not a zero the shapes
become these shapes and I always find
this a little bit of a shock so there
may be some familiar looking shapes oh
no sometimes now even connected together
they're like dusty little particles and
these regions particular when there's
obviously a region which is not a circle
necessarily they're called Julia sets
and again Holly's done a really lovely
video about Julia sets little bit of
history about Julia sets them found by
Gaston Julia hence the name who was a
guy French mathematician I think early
twentieth century he did it without a
computer like he wasn't able to just do
this and move on judge Abreu and see the
boundary he was doing this by hand and
realizing there was some beautiful
structure like I mean every time I tell
the story I'm like best play he also is
really interesting in that he had no
nose genuine you gonna find a picture of
Gaston Julia he has a leather thing
across his face his nose was damaged in
I think the First World War
before I leave Julia entirely the sets
that you can see give you a little bit
of a hint about what's coming so let me
show you two things about the Julia says
first of all the simplest one is a
circle is not that exciting but they are
exciting but they're not always obvious
region sometimes they look like they're
separate regions these don't look like
they're connected the way I'm animating
it here they're all slightly dusty
looking that's just the way I'm making
it happen quickly but sometimes they're
definitely not joined together and
sometimes they look like things you
might recognize the outline it's looking
vaguely like something I've hinted about
this video may be looking like but there
is something important that Holly
mentions in some of her videos about
which ones are joined together connected
mathematically and which ones are
disconnected separate like dust let me
show you what they end up describing so
if we go back to this diagram when I did
the iteration we were originally
starting by you picking a number and a
squaring it what happened in 1979 is a
guy called Benoit now is his first name
didn't get better for me her name was
Mandelbrot is very famous figure in
mathematics these days but it was 1979
nineteen eighty it's kind of recently in
the grand scale of mathematics and while
I was like hmm I wonder what happens if
I always start a zero instead of me
saying pick a number I would say like
pick a number as long as it's zero and
then all I really care about is what's
the constant I at each time and which
ones of those give me stable and which
ones don't
now he didn't have a good computer he
was doing it on an IBM working for IBM
at the time and having to print out on a
dot matrix or probably even pre-dawn
matrix printer but we can kind of
shortcut that so let me show you what it
looks like always start a zero and move
the constant around each time and if you
do that all you'll see is sometimes it's
stable like this and sometimes it's
different stable I just really love this
I'm just going to move around they're
kind of predictable only at no predict
all you get spirally things you get
spider everything sometimes it's not
stable it's unstable
sometimes it's got like how many arms is
that seven arms sometimes it's got three
arms sometimes it's got something else
and sometimes it's just rubbish squaring
and adding these what they call these
are the orbits of for every constant up
pick which you mentioned I picked one
arbitrarily happen to be up in the top
left there this one in fact that's its
orbit but any other concert you pick any
one on the screen has an orbit and some
of them are boring they're just gone and
some of them are not they're stable and
some of them are not quite sure what the
hell's go excuse my English they're the
the idea that maybe some points are
special and someone not is what benot
mandelbrot first began to investigate
other people were investigating it but
it ended up with this idea getting his
name on it
so let me simulate what he first saw
remember he didn't have a monitor on his
computer he had a printer he like type
some code in if you want a picture you
print it like ten minutes later after
you've sold all the printer problems
which still occur weird if you that has
got to go and look what he's like
haven't have I broken the printer or
haven't messed my code up or is what I'm
seeing actually real and what he found
was that what he saw the technicians got
their fur
and they were like he's got it wrong
again and they cleaned up his images and
took all this dog dust but they assumed
were printer artifacts they're like
there's this smudgy bit here tell you
not matter be there we'll just like chop
that off or teleprinter and he
eventually had to go the technician and
say my prints keep coming back different
from what I expected like we're just
cleaning them up he's like stop cleaning
them I think what I'm trying to see is a
weird messy dusty looking thing you know
like oh you want Matt I don't know
exactly what happened there's a really
good book by James glide called
chaos which kind of tells that story
worth a read but I'm gonna simulate the
dusty saw I'm sorry about the lack of
brown paper but there's a reason for the
color this is the same orbit thing I was
showing you just now can you see there's
a lock it's spiral III there but I'm
even a black trail because I'm telling
George Abra to color the screen black if
it's stable and if it's unstable like
that one it goes blue black blue stable
unstable and I'm just gonna scribble on
the screen now this is not gonna make a
good picture but I wonder I want any
kind of to feel what Mandelbrot felt
like so he was seeing black and blue
dots or in this case probably just white
and black dots black for stable and my
case blue for unstable and he started to
wonder why there's a black region here
this that's not over there it's not
symmetrical I really think it must have
felt something like this when you have a
rubbish printer and you don't trust your
code and you wonder what the hell are
you saying so this is going to take ages
right I'm going to shortcut the process
what he eventually saw in higher
resolution than he saw is this picture
and the black regions like I was
coloring earlier are stable you can see
anywhere I go in the black region you
get a nice stable pattern with with
lovely orbits and that's the thing I
love seeing move but if I go over the
edge unstable stable unstable stable
unstable
so it's even stable in this region it
goes into like two piles but if I go
outside the region disappeared if I go
up here you get into three piles and in
fact Holly's done a lovely video on how
many piles you start making depending on
which of these little bulbs you go into
but the first time the Mandelbrot saw
this yet no idea about any of that
structure he just saw a shape which
shocked him first of all it's beautiful
it's kind of weird but getting a viewer
to display it like I've got on the
screen now you can go and watch any
number of YouTube videos and zoom in on
it but you can see what Mandelbrot
couldn't see that he saw this little
blob and thought I wonder what that is
and he had no idea until he wrote his
code better but it was another version
not quite the same and you can just zoom
in forever and now I don't think YouTube
needs more videos of me zooming in on
the Mandelbrot set however I'm going to
do it anyway so the original Mandelbrot
set that Mandelbrot saw was two colors
stable unstable black white or whatever
I did black and blue the colors you're
seeing in this are an arbitrary decision
but they're not as arbitrary as you
might think so let's go back to the
original which is out here black for
stable but the colors indicate that it's
unstable but the color indicates how
unstable and so if you think back to the
very first question I asked you I said
Square it square it square it and within
two iterations you like no because it's
big and that's an indication that you
don't need to ask any more iterations to
know what it's going to do with complex
numbers it's less obvious what it's
going to do is much harder to predict
but eventually we proved mathematicians
as I say we not me mathematicians proved
that if you go outside a circle radius -
it's never coming back but if you inside
you can't guarantee it it might be
bouncing around near the edge and it
might stabilize again and you see some
of the orbits are complicated so all you
do with the computer is you ask it to
check let's say 200 times and if you're
still inside radius to circle off 200
you like let's color it black it's
probably stable but after like 50
iterations if you've just crossed
outside you like or now I know it's gone
maybe the next time you check it takes
sixty iterations and well that's less
unstable maybe I could color that
differently
that was a long way of saying the
different colors on the image are the
different levels of instability really
it's how many times you checked before
you knew they were going to explode and
what matters when you zoom in is that
the colors change really really quickly
so all the colors on the screen here
indicating that a tiny movement of the
original point gives you massively
different behavior and that's become
what we call the sort of hallmark of
chaos theory now is where a tiny change
gives you fundamentally different
behavior on the matter what set your
move your chain every point you made is
depending on which scene you pick but
Julia set you fix one and I can turn
this software into Julia set mode I'll
do it slightly first for press J on here
there's the circle which is the original
Julia set and that's in the middle here
but if I move the mouse around you see
the Julia sets with different values of
C start changing beautifully like I mean
it's just a quick sketch animation but
it's already much more nice than the
outlines you saw earlier and what I love
about this is the Mandelbrot set is kind
of like a map of Julia sets so if you go
and find a bit of the Mandelbrot set
down here this is called seahorse Valley
because it kind of looks like you've got
loads of seahorses spiraling around but
if I switch to a Julia set around this
point it looks the same but am i zoom
out the Julia set you don't degenerate
into Mandelbrot you just get the
seahorse Julia set there it is that's as
big as you get so if you zoom in on the
Mandelbrot set you get little sort of
like regions which are like the Julia
set from that area it's like a map it's
a geography or or vitter ative stability
when you say it like that it sounds
complicated but you just do something
again and again and find out what
happens in the long term and the fact
that it makes something so beautiful I
mean it's it's become so cliche from a
petitions to get excited about but I
still get excited about it because it's
lovely
I didn't design it it's just there we
can explore it I mean just sittin stare
hypnotize at it for hours and you can
program it in ten seconds on a
spreadsheet if you want
so as you said it's not in the
Mandelbrot set right and what that means
so let's call this number say well I've
already used C but let's call it C
anyways